bienvenue sur votre chaîne devait les
relations politiques la chaîne qui vous
explique en quelques minutes les
instances politiques françaises
aujourd'hui on va vous expliquer qu'ils
sont les sénateurs ce qu'ils font et à
quoi ils servent
déjà petit rappel l'organisation d'une
démocratie c'est par les pouvoirs en
trois parties et en france ceux qui
s'occupent de voter les lois
donc qui ont le pouvoir législatif sont
les membres du parlement
le parlement français est divisée en
deux chambres la chambre base c'est la
semaine nationale la chambre haute
c'est le sénat souvent une deuxième
chambre dans un parlement est là pour
représenter des états confédérés comme
le sénat des états unis ou pour
représenter les nobles comme la chambre
des lords en angleterre mais en france
il n'ya pas l'état confédérés et encore
moins de nobles du coup une seule
chambre devrait être suffisante pour
représenter le peuple est en théorie si
on pouvait avoir une assemblée nationale
parfaite
ce serait vrai mais ce n'est pas le cas
et le sénat sert à assurer l'équilibré
pour éviter que la semaine nationale ne
prenne trop de pouvoir et cette décision
d'avoir deux chambres a été prise dès
1795 avec la constitution de la première
république pour la deuxième république
les constituants ont voulu faire avec
une seule chambre mais voyant les
problèmes que ça engendre et lorsque
napoléon iii a pris le pouvoir il a vite
remis une deuxième chambre
aujourd'hui les parlementaires qui
travaille à la semaine nationale sont
les députés ceux qui travaillent au
sénat sont les sénateurs essais des
sénateurs dont on va parler
les sénateurs sont des personnes élues
pour travailler au sénat avec
principalement de rôle faire des lois et
contrôler le gouvernement
ils sont 3 148 et représente l'ensemble
du territoire français et les français
de l'étranger
ils sont élus au suffrage universel
indirect
pendant les élections sénatoriales pour
6 ans et sont renouvelés tous les trois
ans de moitié on dit que c'est un
suffrage indirect car les sénateurs ne
sont pas élu directement par les
citoyens
mais par les représentants des citoyens
et si ce sont seulement les
représentants des collectivités locales
qui votent c'est parce que l'article 24
de la constitution nous dit que le sénat
assure la représentation des
collectivités territoriales de la
république
aussi de la même façon que si on
photographie un paysage sous deux angles
différents
on peut faire ressortir des détails
qu'une seule photo n'aurait pas permis
de voir avoir deux chambres élues
différemment augmente les chances
d'avoir un aperçu plus complexe et plus
riche des besoins et des attentes des
citoyens
les deux chambres permettent de mieux
exprimer la complexité et la diversité
de la nation le nombre de sénateurs par
département dépend du nombre d'habitants
du département
le mode d'élection est partagé entre les
départements peu peuplés et les
départements peu peuplés dans les
départements avec peu d'habitants où il
y à un ou deux sièges de sénateurs
on utilise le scrutin majoritaire à deux
tours dans le département avec plus
d'habitants et où il y a trois sièges de
sénateur ou plus on utilise la
représentation proportionnelle pour
l'exemple
prenons le loir-et-cher et le pas de
calais dans le loir et cher
il n'y a que trois cent trente mille
habitants et donc seulement deux
sénateurs à élire
on utilise donc le scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours
dans le pas de calais il y à un million
quatre cent soixante mille habitants et
sept sénateurs à élire donc cette fois
ci on utilise la représentation
proportionnelle pour expliquer
rapidement la différence entre les deux
scrutins
le scrutin majoritaire ça veut dire que
celui qui a le plus de voix gagne
l'élection comme pour le président la
république alors que pour le scrutin
proportionnel
chaque parti propose une liste de
candidats et les sièges sont répartis
proportionnellement selon le résultat du
scrutin
comme on l'a dit avant les sénateurs
sont des parlementaires et il participe
au travail législatif
ça veut simplement dire que c'est eux
qui se charge de créer des lois de
présenter des lois devant l'assemblée
d'examiner les lois de modifier les lois
et enfin de voter les lois
pour préparer et examiner les lois avant
de les voter dans l'hémicycle les
parlementaires se réunissent en groupes
de travail qu'on appelle commission
parlementaire il existe cette commission
parlementaire au sénat qui sont chacune
experte sur un domaine particulier en ce
qui concerne la loi
[Musique]
une fois une loi votée si 60 sénateurs
pensent qu'elle n'est pas conforme à la
constitution
ils peuvent saisir le conseil
constitutionnel afin de vérifier que le
texte est valide
aussi comme on l'a dit en intro en plus
de la création des lois les sénateurs
participe aussi au contrôle du
gouvernement et pour contrôler le
gouvernement
ils peuvent l'interroger par oral ou
écrit et examiner son action au sein
d'une commission d' enquête ou d'une
mission d'information
[Musique]
mais si je m'arrête ici je sais que
certains vont se dire ouais en gros le
sénat c'est juste une copie de la série
nationale
sauf qu'à l'assemblée ils ont la motion
de censure pour vraiment contrôler le
gouvernement et qu'ils ont le dernier
mot sur le vote des lois et c'est vrai
qu'on entend souvent des critiques sur
l'inutilité supposée du sénat et les
sénateurs mais le sénat à réel poids
dans le processus législatif
il peut proposer de nouvelles lois et
modifier les lois qui lui passe entre
les mains du coup même si le dernier mot
revient à l'assemblée nationale en cas
de désaccord le sénat laisse vraiment
son empreinte dans la création des lois
du pays et son empreinte n'est pas que
sur les lois le sénat participe aussi au
vote du budget de l'état à celui des
modifications de la constitution et à
celui de l'entrée de nouveaux états dans
l'union européenne
et ce deuxième point de vue du sénat est
très important parce qu'il est
relativement indépendant en effet les
sénateurs n'ont pas de lien direct avec
le gouvernement qui émane de la majorité
de l'assemblée nationale mais pas de
celle du sénat et les sénateurs ne
peuvent pas censurer le gouvernement non
plus en plus le sénat ne peut pas être
dissous par le présent la république
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que si le
président la république meurt c'est le
président du sénat qui prend sa place
et cette indépendance par rapport au
gouvernement et au président permet au
sénat d'être un vrai contre-pouvoir
valable car les sénateurs choisissent à
travers leur président trois membres du
conseil constitutionnel sur neuf car les
sénateurs peuvent s'opposer à certaines
nominations du président de la
république et car les sénateurs
participe aussi au jugement des membres
du gouvernement lorsqu'ils sont membres
de la cour de justice de la république
et peuvent destituer le président de la
république lorsque le parlement est
rassemblée en haute cour aussi comme les
sénateurs ne sont pas élu directement
par les citoyens
mais par leurs représentants ils sont en
théorie moins sensibles au populisme
citoyens que les députés
alors on dit souvent que quand même le
sénat ralenti la création des lois à
cause des navettes qui passe deux fois
dans chaque assemblée
et c'est vrai oui mais au fond
est-ce que c'est pas mieux que les
parlementaires prennent leur temps pour
faire des lois en théorie sans erreur
plutôt que de les faire trop vite parce
qu'à force de vouloir faire des lois
trop rapidement le parlement se retrouve
parfois avec des lois difficile à mettre
en place ou sur lesquels il doit revenir
plus tard
ce qui au final prend énormément de
temps en plus si on va accélérer
l'adoption des lois des outils il y en a
et si vous ne voyez pas de quoi je parle
regardez notre vidéo sur les ordonnances
contre 49,3 et vous aurez des indices
donc pour résumer les sénateurs sont des
parlementaires qui ont deux grands rôles
de création des lois et de contrôle du
gouvernement
leur présence permet d'apporter un
contre-pouvoir par rapport à l'assemblée
nationale avec une certaine indépendance
vis-à-vis du peuple du gouvernement ou
du président
donc voilà cette vidéo est terminée
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu n'hésitez
pas à laisser un commentaire ou un pouce
bleus vous pouvez en retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux twitter et facebook
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et à
très bientôt